[Music]
on this wednesday night the state of
emergency on a manitoba cree nation
the crisis enveloping the community and
the pleas for help
as manitoba's indigenous affairs
minister quits
kovitz resurgence in the u.s what it
could mean
for the border nobody wants to have to
go backwards
plus the debate about whether to mandate
vaccines for students
the eu says it's now or never its
ambitious pledge to be carbon neutral
plus sounds from the deep just such a
risky
a risky proposition what a canadian
researcher recorded in the deepest known
point
of the world's oceans
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with a tragic situation
unfolding on a northern manitoba first
nation
that to tasquiah cree nation is asking
for help
and has declared a state of emergency
because of recent deaths and
incidents of self-harm the community of
split lake is about 700 kilometers north
of winnipeg
about 2300 people live there and in a
news release the first nation says we
have reached a breaking point
and our community is under crisis with
alcohol and drugs
contributing to it the community has
reached out to mobile crisis teams and
is asking for additional support from
health canada indigenous services canada
the rcmp and the province of manitoba
it says it needs long-term solutions
such as 24
7 in community mental health counseling
the first nation is also dealing with a
water emergency it's been under a
drinking water advisory since 2017
and has launched a class action lawsuit
against the federal government
over that our chief political
correspondent david aiken
reached the chief of that cree nation
david
what else did she tell you
right and that chief is chief doreen
spence and we did speak this afternoon
her and two of her band counselors and
she really talked about a community that
really became completely overwhelmed by
a mental health crisis
here's some of what you had to say
everybody's um
hurt and and in disbelief of what's
happening
to our young people and this is a
wake-up call for us too that you know
we have to do something to help our
people
now as i mentioned chief spence spoke to
me with two of her band counselors and
they wanted to stress that the whole
council
the community very much behind this
decision to declare an act of emergency
and it's
for a mental health crisis the kind of
crisis they've never seen in their
community before
they have nine deaths by suicide in the
last 14 months
and it is all young people people
between the age of 15
and 19. it's a you know community of
2300 2600 depending
at the time like many small towns
perhaps across canada
they simply didn't have the resources to
deal with this kind of mental health
crisis
and that's why they have reached out for
help
we're in a desperate situation here
right now we don't want to lose any more
youth
and so we have to we need
anyone out there that is willing to help
our community
to contact us in terms of what they can
support
now alcohol and drug abuse absolutely
the common denominator
with all these deaths and with some
continuing problems in the community
but it's more than that certainly the
lockdowns associated with the
pandemic have contributed to the
melt-to-health crisis and
that's just not in that community but in
many communities across the country
another big contributing factor the
chief telling me today and the
counselors
is the discovery of the unmarked graves
at residential schools across the
country this has been
a punch in the gut not just to elders in
that community
but to indigenous youth in this
particular community as well
that is contributing to the crisis so
they've reached out for help they have
some initial contacts with the federal
government
they're hoping to hear more about
getting more resources into the
community
as quickly as they can to reverse this
crisis
donna so much intergenerational
trauma david aiken in ottawa thanks
there is
some support for those who need it the
canada suicide prevention service line
is available
in canada 24 hours a day the number is
toll-free you can speak in confidence
1-833-456
is the number manitoba's minister of
indigenous and northern relations has
resigned after comments premier brian
pallister made last week
eileen clark isn't commenting on exactly
why she quit the cabinet
last week premier pallister chastised
people involved in tearing down statues
of queen victoria and queen elizabeth on
the grounds
of the manitoba legislature on canaday
canada day and said the statues will be
restored we need to respect our heritage
just as we need to respect one another
not to find fault not to tear down
not to highlight every failure but
rather to realize that we're a complex
country as we are made up of complex
people
the people who came here to this country
uh before it was a country and since
didn't come here to destroy anything
they came here to build
they came to build better
when asked about those comments today
brian pallister said this
i don't stand by my comments i continue
to advocate that we
build and not destroy and i'll continue
to say
that we can work together and then when
we do we'll accomplish great things
pallister was asked what reason his
cabinet minister eileen clark
gave him for stepping down he refused to
comment clark
also declined to say anything out of
respect she says for the assembly of
manitoba chief's election
which is happening today now to some
breaking news out of toronto city
council there has voted in favor of
renaming
dundas street and other toronto
landmarks bearing the dundas name
the push to rename the street gained
traction last year when thousands of
people signed a petition
during anti-racism protests the street
was named after henry dundas an 18th
century scottish politician
who helped delay britain's abolition of
slavery the city says it will begin
consultations on choosing a new name
well schools are already planning
for the fall and there is growing debate
around whether vaccinations should be
mandatory for students and staff at
post-secondary schools
more than half of canadians are fully
vaccinated but when it comes to people
aged
18 to 29 only 21 percent have both shots
as mike delay reports schools may have a
tough decision to make
it's a canadian post-secondary first if
you want to attend seneca college in
person in the fall
be prepared to show proof of a covet 19
vaccine
otherwise stay online we're not forcing
anybody actually the we're actually not
making
vaccines mandatory we're saying if you
want to come on campus
you must be vaccinated it's a decision
seneca president david agnew says he
made
with the safety of his students in mind
honestly i
i would love government to come in and
say these are the rules of the road
because that makes it easier for
everybody
but we can't wait and the ontario
government doesn't appear to be in a
hurry
declining to give a firm answer to
global news on its plans
as far as immunizations go only ontario
new brunswick
and recently bc have required students
to be vaccinated against childhood
illnesses
epidemiologists see covet 19 as a
logical addition to that list
this is this herd immunity notion right
you have a wall people get vaccinated
all you need
is some not to be vaccinated and the
virus sneaks through
so the notion of well i don't need to be
vaccinated because i'm going to be okay
it's ridiculous protect us you know get
this wall up
so we'll get down to zero coronavirus
and we can get on with life
yet it's a debate with seemingly no
middle ground it's either a question of
public health or individual rights
western university says students must be
vaccinated to live in campus dorms
this coming school year others may
follow
in the u.s schools have been quicker to
act more than 500 post-secondary
institutions
including harvard and berkeley have
already committed to mandatory student
vaccinations
you know the social fabric of the united
states and canada is
is similar but boy it sure isn't
identical
and you know we're looking at this
through a canadian lens of how we view
our own rights and responsibilities so
in some ways it's not that surprising
that canada is struggling with this one
it's an issue he says worthy of debate
but halfway through july
how much time do we have microlight
global news toronto
in the u.s a spike in covet 19 cases is
making the reopening of the canada u.s
border more uncertain
cases are nowhere near their what they
were at the peak but they are
climbing fast in the last two weeks in
florida cases jumped 257 percent
public health experts say the highly
transmissible delta variant and pockets
with low vaccination rates
are to blame jackson proskow reports
months of progress have been wiped out
in just a few short days
the highly contagious delta variant is
spreading rapidly in the u.s
case numbers are climbing in 45 out of
50 states
it's looking different it's feeling
different we're seeing the increase
in transmissibility that we know is
characteristic
of the delta variant it's happening
fastest in communities with low rates of
inoculation
in mississippi where just 33 percent of
the population
is fully vaccinated the surge has left
seven children in intensive care
two are on ventilators hospitals in
missouri have reopened their covet wards
99 percent of those requiring treatment
are not vaccinated
in this phase of the pandemic there's
really two life choices
it's to vaccinate or you're going to get
coveted
los angeles county has reported more
than one thousand cases per day
each of the last five days and is once
again recommending masks even for the
fully vaccinated
i think we have to be to be very very
cautious we're at a tipping point right
now this variant is taking hold it's
becoming dominant it's extremely
contagious
the renewed u.s surge could complicate
the long-awaited reopening of the
canada-u.s
border we are not through this pandemic
yet current restrictions are likely to
be extended before they expire next week
ottawa wants 75 percent of canadians to
be fully vaccinated first
and has warned further easing depends on
how the virus evolves
as eager as people are to open up
i know nobody wants to have to go
backwards
back in the u.s the cdc is now
predicting an increase in
hospitalizations and deaths for the
first time since the spring
as experts warn of the potential for new
variants to emerge
in the mix between vaccinated and
unvaccinated americans
we've left the door open for the virus
to learn everything it needs to to get
around that vaccine that we
desperately worked so hard to get
jackson prosko global news washington
in kelowna b.c the body of a fifth
person who died when a construction
crane collapsed has now been recovered
part of the crane landed on a building
where a man was working
four construction workers were also
killed robin gill is in kelowna and she
spoke to the father
of one of them chris vilnius had to see
for himself the place where his son died
our family's close i've got four kids
and you take one out of the equation
it's
it takes away from the dynamic of your
family it was 20 thrilled kaelin's
first day on the job when a crane
crumbled sending pieces of steel
crashing down they asked him
specifically to
take down the crane so when i saw the
crane down i knew he was
on the crane and he thought the worst
the family can't stop looking at this
video taken of the crane as it was being
removed
desperate to understand what went wrong
that's kalyn
on the left he'd worked for stemmer
construction before
and was excited about coming back for
the new job the bc company is family run
and has been since its founding in 1990.
it was a subcontractor on a kelowna
high-rise under construction
the founder lost his own two sons eric
and patrick stammer
patrick was the crane operator jared
zuck from edmonton was also killed
this would be the worst structural
collapse that i've responded a team of
firefighters from vancouver helped
recover a fifth man who was working in a
building
next to the one under construction crews
say he didn't stand a chance
when the crane hit the objects from the
crane had come
through the roof and the roof was
essentially completely gone
global news requested information about
stemmer construction safety record but
the provincial agency in charge says it
will take
days at minimum for our questions to be
answered
the union representing engineers in
construction is demanding
more oversight of crane operators it's
critical that people are skilled
and trained to be able to do the work
it's
it's the most critical part of the
process
dismantling or erecting the tower crane
chris vilnis himself a construction
manager has questions about
how this tragedy could have happened but
he needs to deal with his grief
first you can't even put it in your
brain
or don't even want to the feeling that
comes across you when you get the news
it
is unbelievable
now two cranes have been brought in to
stabilize the situation
and somehow figure out how they're going
to remove the one that's at the center
of the investigation
but even investigators can't get access
to the scene so it could be weeks
possibly months
before we find out what went so wrong
donna
all right robin gill in kelowna bc
thanks
a promise for the planet coming up how
the eu plans to be carbon neutral by
2050.
the crisis in the canadian military and
all the allegations of sexual misconduct
have made headlines for months
at the same time there's been a steep
increase in the number of people
submitting claims for a class-action
lawsuit against the government
as abigail beeman reports it appears
people are becoming
more comfortable coming forward it
wasn't until i
got into therapy that i realized how
much the 80s
assaults actually affected my life sam
samplonius's military career began
40 years ago she says she was sexually
assaulted three times in the 1980s
then again in 2016. it's been emotional
it's it's certainly affected my family
i'm now divorced while she personally
had to withdraw from the class action
lawsuit to pursue a civil case against
her alleged abuser
she attributes a recent spike in claims
to a positive culture change
they're realizing that their feelings
are valid
the traumas that happen to them are
valid and i think now that people
really understand that people will
believe them and not look at them as
some sort of
weirdo the class action opened to claims
in may 2020 by december
of that year there were nearly three
thousand of them
now there are well over seven thousand
claims
that's a one hundred and seventy percent
spike in six months
there are still four months left to
submit a claim there's a presumption
that the stories and narrative the
experiences that people relay will be
accepted as being true people won't be
questioned
they won't be interviewed there's no
expectation that they
previously raised these issues one
lawyer working on the lawsuit says
they've worked to make the process
non-adversarial and they pass along any
issues they hear
somebody receiving an email that says
hey
congratulations your sexual harassment
or
sexual assault allegations are
recognized as real
and this is extremely traumatic for some
people
those close to the class action tell
global news while the process can be
emotional one claimant called it
excruciating there's also a tremendous
amount of healing that comes through it
all hoping that separate from the payout
of up to 900 million dollars
this will create real and lasting change
going forward
abigail beeman global news ottawa
still ahead canadian soldiers lament the
taliban takeover of afghanistan
the u.s government says it will get a
group of afghans who worked with
american forces
out of the country their lives are at
risk if they stay
and canada too has been under pressure
to give safe haven to afghans who worked
with our troops the taliban are
regaining more control of the country
every day
and as mike armstrong explains canada's
top soldier
is speaking out
this is a taliban video shot this month
at the afghanistan pakistan border
the spin a spot called the friendship
gate the taliban flag now flies over it
[Music]
in 2007 a global national team visited
the same spot
afghan border police controlled the
crossing with the support of canadian
troops
and equipment provided by nato seeing
places like the friendship gate fall as
being hard on the soldiers
who tried to help canada's acting chief
of the defense staff released an open
letter tuesday night to serving
and retired soldiers in it he says the
fall of areas canadians fought to
protect
has hit many of us particularly hard the
current trajectory of the country
leaves us with much pain and doubt
the goal of lieutenant general wayne
ayers letter was to help soldiers who
served in afghanistan
who may be struggling hearing the news
of taliban advances
he tells the troops to focus on their
commitment to service
to honor the sacrifice and to reach out
if they need support
we're watching these scenes we were
there
retired soldier chris dupey says
watching the news lately has been like a
punch in the
gut seeing people he tried to help now
back
under the thumb of the taliban seeing
the
families fleeing and getting shot at
that's that's really you know
really disheartening and heartbreaking
president bush
now there is new criticism of the u.s
decision to pull out of afghanistan
in an interview with a german
broadcaster former president george bush
says progress has been made
and will be lost sadly
i'm afraid afghan women and girls are
going to suffer unspeakable
harm is it a mistake it's a withdrawal
you know i think it is
the united nations refugee agency says
violence has forced
hundreds of thousands from their homes
just since january and getting aid to
them without a peace deal is getting
more and more difficult
the taliban advances make that peace
deal less
and less likely mike armstrong global
news
the european union has laid out a plan
to drastically cut greenhouse gas
emissions
saying the world is at a now or never
moment the eu plan includes tighter
emissions limits for cars effectively
ending sales of new gas and diesel cars
by 2035
introducing a carbon tax on aviation and
shipping fuel
and a carbon levy on non-european
manufacturers who'd have to pay more to
import materials like steel
and concrete and the principle
is simple emission of co2 must have
a price a price on co2 that incentivizes
consumer
producers and innovators to choose
the clean technologies to go towards the
clean and sustainable products
the aim is to wean europe off fossil
fuels through strict policies rather
than be forced into desperate measures
sometime in the future there is no time
to waste
people are dying in northwest canada
because it's 50 degrees celsius there
northwest canada
siberia reaches temperatures over 35
degrees
and central europe is over 40 degrees we
saw tornadoes in the czech republic who
would ever
have thought of that so anyone who wants
to
deny the urgency of the climate crisis
should look again
the plan has to be passed by the
european parliament it would impose
legally binding targets to reduce net eu
emissions by 55
by 2030 from 1990 levels and
eliminate them by 2050.
deep sound waves next when a canadian
recorded 11 kilometers under the sea
a canadian researcher has recorded audio
from the deepest part of the ocean it's
an amazing achievement the mariana
trench is
one of the most extreme environments on
earth the equipment that went down had
to withstand intense pressure and as
ross lord reports the secret
sound of the sea floor is finally
surfacing
for oceanographer david barclay sending
a high-tech gizmo
to the deepest part of the world's
oceans was a success
in part because his research equipment
even survived the trip
there's always an only a half
expectation that will get the equipment
back
because it's just such a risky a risky
proposition sending it down there
barclays research in april was centered
at a section of the mariana trench
called the challenger deep
at 11 kilometers down water pressure is
so intense there it would destroy many
normal scientific instruments
his lander is one of few to successfully
complete the research
using sensors to measure water
temperature salt content
and sound so we want to measure the
water properties
throughout the entire range of ocean
depth
including only the second audio
recordings ever
from the challenger deep some of the
early sounds were
unnerving
shards of glass chipping off from the
lander
at the very bottom near total silence
in one of the quietest underwater
locations on the planet
but for the ripples of waves breaking
tens of thousands of meters above
the lander was recovered data intact
providing barclay and his colleagues
with an opportunity to analyze its
findings
to understand how does the human use of
the ocean
impact the acoustic environment of the
of the open ocean
parkway says he's already begun
developing a model that can predict
ocean properties far beneath the surface
findings that could lead to better
nautical charts for mariners
and a more detailed map of the sea floor
itself
new efforts to understand our planet and
the oceans that cover most of it
ross lord global news
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is lunenburg nova scotia one
of only two urban communities in north
america designated
a un world heritage site thanks for
watching take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye